Even though we're only a few months into the
new decade, the 2020s have already been defined
by an international health crisis known as
COVID-19.
After originating in the Wuhan province of
China, this particularly dangerous form of
coronavirus has spread throughout the world
at a much faster rate than most could have
anticipated, creating a worldwide atmosphere
of fear as a virus deadlier than the seasonal
flu strikes the most vulnerable populations.
To try and prevent the incredibly rapid spread
of COVID-19, some countries are limiting travel
and closing their borders after a terrible
outbreak, Italy placed limits on all travel
and put its residents under a strict quarantine,
essentially closing some of the world's most
historically relevant major cities and unsurprisingly,
this shutdown is also affecting the entertainment
industry in a big way.
Film festivals and premieres are getting rescheduled
and canceled right and left, and between quarantined
shooting locations, contaminated cast and
crew members, and concerns about crowds attending
new movies, a lot of projects have ground
to a screeching halt in the face of COVID-19.
One of the first cinematic casualties of COVID-19
was the final outing for Daniel Craig as James
Bond, halting one of the biggest movies of
the spring season.
In early March of 2020, MGM, Universal, and
the producers of No Time to Die announced
that the film's original release of April
10, 2020 would no longer come to fruition,
and the film would instead have to wait until
November 25, 2020.
"You're late."
In a statement obtained by the BBC, the producers
explained their reasoning, saying,
"Just one person, who may not even show symptoms,
could infect the rest of the audience.
It's just a movie.
The health and well-being of fans around the
world, and their families, is more important.
We have all waited over four years for this
film.
Another few months will not damage the quality
of the film and only help the box office for
Daniel Craig's final hurrah."
Though some Bond fans will definitely be disappointed
by this delay, it's clear that the reasoning
behind the choice wasn't just sound, but extraordinarily
considerate to those most affected by this
virus.
Certainly, Craig and crew wanted fans to see
their newest film as soon as possible, but
this humane and prescient decision will absolutely
protect people from this viral outbreak, as
well as drum up even more anticipation for
Craig's final Bond film.
As COVID-19 spreads, the atmosphere surrounding
this pandemic is becoming more tense and frightening,
and as such, a stark dystopian tale about
an alien apocalypse might not be a huge theatrical
success right at this exact moment.
That might be just one reason as to why A
Quiet Place Part II, the sequel to John Krasinski's
directorial horror debut which premiered to
rave reviews in 2018, has been officially
placed on the backburner for the spring release
season.
In a statement, Paramount announced that though
they were placing A Quiet Place Part 2 on
a temporary hold, they don't yet have a new
release date for the film, which finds Emily
Blunt's character trying to protect her family
in a world where monsters can track your every
sound.
Producers for the movie said in a statement,
"After much consideration, and in light of
the ongoing and developing situation concerning
coronavirus and restrictions on global travel
and public gatherings, Paramount Pictures
will be moving the worldwide release of A
Quiet Place Part II.
We believe in and support the theatrical experience,
and we look forward to bringing this film
to audiences this year once we have a better
understanding of the impact of this pandemic
on the global theatrical marketplace."
The CW's wildest teen show is also facing
delays as a result of COVID-19, leading the
residents of Riverdale in the lurch.
The Archie Comics adaptation, which also faced
a series of hardships in 2019 due to the unexpected
death of series star Luke Perry, was forced
to halt production as a result of possible
contamination.
The Hollywood Reporter announced that the
Vancouver-set production put a hold on shooting
its upcoming fourth season, out of an abundance
of caution after someone on the show's team
may have come in contact with the virus.
At the time of the announcement, the delay
was open-ended.
Though Riverdale fans will undoubtedly be
disappointed, the health of the cast and crew
is obviously the most important consideration
for the show.
If fans were hoping that the next Fast & Furious
film would arrive on... well, a fast and furious
schedule, it looks like they'll be disappointed.
"You think this is a joke?
Huh?"
In the wake of the COVID-19 outbreak, Fast
& Furious 9 is facing a serious delay, moving
its release date by a full year to accommodate
audiences trying to avoid this virus.
Universal Studios announced that the film
would be delayed nearly a full year, jumping
from May 22, 2020 to April 2, 2021.
As the team said on Twitter,
"We feel all the love and the anticipation
you have for the next chapter in our saga.
That's why it's especially tough to let you
know that we have to move the release date
of the film.
It's become clear that it won't be possible
for all of our fans around the world to see
the film this May."
Though the Fast & Furious crew knows their
fans are bummed, they reassured their loyal
followers that the decision was made with
safety in mind:
"While we know there is disappointment in
having to wait a little while longer, this
move is made with the safety of everyone as
our foremost consideration.
Moving will allow our global family to experience
our new chapter together.
We'll see you next spring."
Even the Marvel Cinematic Universe isn't immune
to coronavirus concerns.
Along with several other Disney projects,
the upcoming Disney+ show The Falcon and the
Winter Soldier, which follows Anthony Mackie
and Sebastian Stan as Sam Wilson and Bucky
Barnes, has been delayed due to this growing
pandemic.
Exactly what effect this will have on the
series' intended Fall 2020 premiere remains
to be seen.
"That's smart.
Good strategy."
The production was shut down while filming
in Prague, in the heart of the Czech Republic.
Stan took to Instagram to address Marvel fans,
lavishing praise upon Prague and the production
itself with the caption,
"Prague.
What a city.
We've been shooting TheFalconAndTheWinterSoldier
and experiencing one of the most beautiful
cities in the world filled with the most wonderful
and welcoming people.
Now we are being sent home.
Too soon.
Prague, you're gonna be in my thoughts for
a long time.
Thank you.
Will be back.
Thinking of you."
These two superheroes might be unstoppable
in the MCU, but COVID-19 has put their story
into cryo-freeze for now.
In the midst of a frightening pandemic, audiences
are looking for escapist fare more than ever,
but unfortunately, some upcoming romantic
comedies are getting shelved until further
notice due to the virus.
One such casualty is The Lovebirds, Paramount's
upcoming rom-com starring Issa Rae and Kumail
Nanjiani, which has been pulled from the studio's
lineup.
Ahead of its planned April 3, 2020 release,
the Michael Showalter film has been placed
on an indefinite hold, with no new release
date announced just yet.
Fans of animated Disney classics — and their
live-action remakes — were surely disappointed
when the studio announced that their highly
anticipated live-action reboot of Mulan would
also face delays due to the coronavirus crisis.
Before the film's planned release on March
27, Disney broke the news that Mulan would
simply have to wait.
"It is decided.
Come and sit down."
Per Niki Caro, the film's director, the decision
was made out of respect to the global pandemic,
and she took to Instagram to explain the film's
unfortunate delay, writing, in part,
"We are so excited to share this film with
the world, but given the current ever-shifting
circumstances we are all experiencing, unfortunately,
we have to postpone the worldwide release
of MULAN for now.
Our hearts are with everyone the world over
who is affected by this virus, and we hope
that Mulan's fighting spirit will continue
to inspire those who are working so hard to
keep us all safe.”
Currently, there's no new release date set
just yet for Mulan.
Sometimes, when a film faces delay after delay
after delay, it seems like it might never
see the light of day; unfortunately, that
seems to be the case for the X-Men spin-off
The New Mutants.
After facing multiple delays due to a number
of factors, including Fox's acquisition by
Disney, and rumors of reshoots that apparently
didn't even end up happening, The New Mutants
has been delayed yet again thanks to the ongoing
threat of coronavirus.
This news comes after questions over whether
or not Disney would even release the film,
which was one of the holdovers from Fox's
theatrical schedule, but it ended up with
an April 3rd release date...
“Not anymore.”
… only to be pulled yet again, with no new
release date as of the making of this video.
Smaller films are likely to take an even bigger
hit when it comes to delayed releases.
Antlers, a daring indie horror film starring
Keri Russell and Jesse Plemons, is just one
example.
With a planned April 17th release by Searchlight
Pictures, Antlers, which is directed by Crazy
Heart helmer Scott Cooper and produced by
horror auteur Guillermo del Toro, has been
delayed by parent company Disney.
Like some of Disney's other delays, including
the much pricier Mulan and The New Mutants,
Antlers also has no planned release date as
of the making of this video.
The coronavirus-related delays and cancellations
are coming out of Hollywood at a fast and
furious pace, indeed, per Variety.
As of the making of this video, you can add
CBS reality TV staples Survivor and Amazing
Race to the list.
Both shows have temporarily shut down production
on their current seasons.
Season 2 production of Apple’s The Morning
Show, starring Reese Witherspoon and Jennifer
Aniston, is also going on a two-week hiatus,
effective immediately.
Long-running hospital drama Grey’s Anatomy
is also getting delayed, but the diagnosis
isn’t too dire.
The current season is basically in the can,
with 21 out of a planned 25 episodes filmed.
Out of an abundance of caution, however, the
showrunners have halted production “for
at least two weeks” in response to the virus.
As for films, production on the Baz Lurhmann
directed “Untitled Elvis Project“ has
been halted, along with the highly anticipated
Mission Impossible: 7 with Tom Cruise and
the comedy Official Competition, starring
Penelope Cruz and Antonio Banderas.
And sorry, kids: the release of Sony’s Peter
Rabbit 2 has been pushed back from late March/early
April to August 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.